Aaron is with us in Kansas City hi Aaron
how are you hey Dave I'm doing all right
good how can I help hey my wife and I
are basically on baby step 4
yeah so we've got about $20,000 in the
bank and it turns out that we're
pregnant with triplets exciting however
we just moved into our house and we're
gonna have to do some remodeling so
would you recommend taking that that
$20,000 to do the remodeling or is it
better to do a home equity line credit
better not to date and remodeling well
we're at 10 kids now so you are blessed
unbelievable
we are blessed Wow okay so the $20,000
is your emergency fund right ah okay in
order to use that money you have to
declare this to be an emergency well my
wife and I definitely feel that it's an
emergency with the kids coming and just
not having enough space for them okay
what is your household income well right
now it's about 12,000 a month but my
wife will have to be dropping out of the
workforce so it's been go down to about
8,000 a month okay and what is the
extent of the renovations what is it
going to cost you well we haven't gotten
the final price back but it'll be really
close to that $20,000 okay so you're
willing to have 10 kids and no money in
a renovated house wow that's a big
emergency
so what I'm probably doing if I'm in
your shoes is I'm gonna cash flow this
renovation during this pregnancy out of
this wonderful household income and
leave my emergency fund alone okay like
I don't know $3,000 $4,000 a month
you're gonna have no life but you you
gotta get the ring renovation done I
just had scared me to death to have ten
kids and zero money yeah it screamed
to have 10 kids in a home equity loan -
yeah as you can't run the dead every
time you have a problem do it if you do
you're gonna be broke your whole life
yeah Mike you know because my wife gonna
have to go out the workforce for
probably a year yeah and and then when
she gets back and you know we'll get our
income back up but yeah but that's four
thousand at the a of the twelve right
yeah you got $8,000 anytime you got a
lot of mouths to feed but you got a good
income so and you got no dad right
except the house right and how much is
your house payment two thousand two
hundred a month okay well if you guys
get on a really tight written budget
where every dollar has an assignment
every month you know I'm gonna squeeze
that budget real tight because this is
important to do this renovation
apparently I don't I mean you're the one
saying it is I'm not there I can't even
imagine triplets or ten kids either one
but Wow Wow so but I got to tell you
this I had the idea of being a zero
money even with $100,000 your income
scares me to death
and I can't tell you to go into debt I
think that's suicide so I think you got
some bad choices here to make and I'm
gonna do my best to cashflow it to avoid
the bad choices